ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
Jordan has no life which is at least a
top 50 systems Design Channel on YouTube
today you'll be witnessing me performing
an sdui AKA systems design Under the
Influence as I just get back from my
company happy hour I was supposed to
record this thing last night and in fact
I did do so however of course when I
actually checked the footage my
microphone was not turned on and I
immediately raged and threw a tantra so
let's go ahead and talk about spark one
more time before I go insane have a good
one and I will see you in the iPad
alright so as it turns out today we're
talking about Apache spark this is a
tool that a lot of Engineers use but in
my experience is probably one that a lot
of Engineers don't understand why it is
that they're using so let's get started
by talking about that why would we use
spark well in order to understand that
we must first understand why mapreduce
sucks probably even harder than my
ex-girlfriend so let's get started there
mapreduce has three main issues with it
so let's touch upon all three the first
being that as I mentioned in a couple of
videos ago in mapreduce if we want to
express more complex functionality we'll
use chain jobs now chain jobs don't know
about one another effectively you're
just saying do job number one then do
job number two then do job number three
and what that means is that we have lots
of waiting so for example let's imagine
we finished this part of our mapreduce
job one but then this part is like
lollygagging over here we can't get
started on this part of mapreduce job
number two until this guy is done and so
this guy is just idly waiting right it
doesn't really do anything and as a
result we're just wasting our own time a
second thing is that each job requires a
mapper and reducer and frankly after
mapping one time a lot of the time we
don't really need another mapper
especially because keep in mind that
mappers actually perform sorting
functionality and doing a bunch of
unnecessary sorting is n log n
complexity which is super costly when
it's on a big data set such as the ones
we're using in batch processing now
number three is that we have tons of
disk usage so the issue with having tons
of disk usage is that obviously it's
expensive but mapreduce in particular
uses lots of disk because jobs
materialize an intermediate state so
keep in mind that every mapreduce job
goes from disk to disk and when we're
chaining them
we only care about the first and the
last outcome we don't care about this
middle guy right here and so wouldn't it
be great if we just didn't ever write
that to our hard drive because that
wastes a ton of time
so these are three main reasons why
mapreduce sucks and as a result of that
spark tries to improve upon all three of
these things so how does it do it let's
take a look at the architecture of a
typical spark job so what spark will
actually do and imagine we've got three
nodes in our Hadoop cluster here
performing a batch computation is it
will only write things to disk on input
and on output as you can see which is
super great but in addition to that as
opposed to using mappers and reducers
every single function that we want to
perform on our data is expressed as an
operator and operators can basically
have arbitrary code unlike mappers and
reducers where there's typically some
mapping phase a sorting phase a shuffle
and then a reduction operators can
basically do anything so you'll see an
example of an operator right here that
could be something like a mapping where
you're taking certain data and then
putting it into the next phase and then
here's one where we're actually doing
some shuffling where we're
re-partitioning our data and then here's
another example of a map or something
like that could be a reduce as well who
knows
so what also makes spark special is this
guy right here in between which is where
we actually hold our data and this is
known as an rdd or a resilient
distributed
data set I believe that's where it
stands for don't quote me on that I'm
drunk but
assuming that that's what rdd does stand
for which I'm pretty sure it is the
important thing about rdds are they are
in memory and as a result of being in
memory it means that we can avoid
writing our intermediate state to disk
and by doing so we speed up our
performance significantly in addition of
course since spark is aware of the
entire object computation graph for a
query it can actually just go ahead and
get started with computations as soon as
all of the data is available from the
previous steps so that's very important
to know
so spark can speed things up a lot
however you should now be thinking to
yourself shoot if spark is doing
everything in its intermediate States in
memory what happens if we fail in the
middle of the way of our spark job that
is going to be where we spend the
remainder of this video
so spark basically looks at a potential
Quarry plan right and a query plan is
going to look similar to this last slide
over here where it basically draws out
all the dependencies of all the stages
of that spark job and it's going to
Define every single operator as two
types of things basically a narrow
dependency or a wide dependency so what
is a narrow dependency a narrow
dependency is basically when you know
all computation
stays on one node
between two steps of the spark job so
what would be an example of that let's
say we've got a bunch of messages here
with the following keys
and then we've got some messages
corresponding to them and we basically
say for every single message get the
number of characters in that message
hence why we have three and four and et
cetera et cetera et cetera that's going
to be a narrow dependency because we
don't have to do any shuffling of data
to move on to the next step we're
literally just counting the number of
characters and that entire step is local
to the node where the data lives
so what actually happens in a narrow
dependency type of situation where we
have a fault of our Hardware let's say
that this guy right here
A3 and B4 goes down
so keep in mind that again we don't have
access to this anymore because this was
in memory but we do probably have access
to some sort of replica of it so we
still have the original data that came
from disk so we'll typically end up
doing here is because this is a narrow
dependency we know that all of the
computation for these steps can be
re-performed on any given machine and so
what we'll typically do to make that as
fast as possible is we'll actually
parallelize it so typically we would
move one piece of data over to the other
nodes in our cluster and basically split
that up accordingly
and then we could parallelize the
computation of that narrow dependency
such that we basically just go ahead and
split it up amongst the remaining nodes
in the cluster and as you can see now
what we've done is basically just remake
up all of that compute and that's great
we can rerun everything it'll be
relatively fast because if one node
fails we can split up that work amongst
a bunch of other nodes and we're good to
go however things aren't always this
simple
sometimes what we have are wide
dependencies so this is a little bit
more challenging to explain but the
example of our wide dependency in this
case is going to be this guy here the
reason it's a wide dependency is because
unlike narrow dependencies where all of
the data from one step to another is
contained locally on one node in a wide
dependency we actually have to rely on
data from other nodes in order to get
our computation done for the next step
so let's say for example that A3 A6 went
down right here right this is going to
be node number one
let's say in t equals three this guy
goes down so the issue right now is that
we need to be able to recompute this
state right here but we can also
recompute this whole state without also
having access to this state and this
state and this state now keep in mind
this guy is down this entire node and
more importantly another issue right now
is that this guy is no longer in memory
because we moved on to the next step
over here at T equals three and now we
no longer have access to our previous
state
so what does spark do to actually deal
with wide dependencies and basically the
issue of them being hard to recover from
well it'll say Okay a T3
we just got past a wide dependency so
right now what we're going to do is
write to disk
so basically whenever spark sees a wide
dependency and whenever we finish
dealing with that wide dependency we
write our data to disk the reason for
that being that it's very hard to
recover from these so in the event that
say a equals 9 goes down what we can
actually do is we recover our state from
disk
and I'm now realizing that that might be
hard to see so I'll write it again down
here we recover from disk
and then what you'll notice is from T
equals 3 to T equals 4 we only have
narrow dependencies narrow narrow narrow
and then we would resolve this problem
in the same way that we would with a
typical narrow dependency where I would
take a03 over here I would take a 6 over
here and then we would go ahead and
parallelize that computation as expected
with a narrow dependency and so the
general solution or the general point
I'm trying to make here is four wide
dependencies will occasionally have to
check point to disk and that is a little
bit more expensive but it allows us to
be fully fault tolerant which is great
so what is the conclusion in terms of
using spark what do I really want you to
take away from this video well for
number one it's certainly much faster
than mapreduce right because a nodes
will do computations as soon as the data
is available number two is that all of
the immediate state that uh you know we
don't really need to be writing to disk
is generally kept in memory of course
the exception to this is right after we
finish a wide dependency in which case
we temporarily materialize things to
disk so that we can make sure that we're
fault tolerant and number three and also
very important is that we don't have to
sort our data at every single step if we
have huge data sets this is extremely
time consuming at the same time spark
does use more memory than mapreduce
whereas mapreduce can basically keep
things on disk and due to sorting make
sure that the memory footprint is
relatively Low Spark is keeping all of
our computation state in an rdd and as a
result of that technically our compute
cluster may be using more memory during
a spark job than it would during a
mapreduce job and technically what that
means is that if we have certain other
things that we want to be doing with our
cluster there might be less memory
available nonetheless there's a reason
that you see everyone using spark and
that is because this speed benefit is
extremely extremely noticeable and as a
result spark is a great technology
anyways guys I hope you have a great
rest of the weekend I am going to enjoy
this drunkness right now and so I will
see you in the next one